leute so kratzig koch zwischen
verschiedenen öffentlich gemacht also
leute ist es ist einfach crazy ich bin
in berlin gerade ich war gestern bei
einem netflix event und bin gestern ins
hotel eingecheckt und die leute an mir
freundlicherweise ein upgrade gegeben
und ich habe es auch die dickste suite
des jahrhunderts also
es ist wirklich crazy also man kommt
rein geht nach rechts und dann ist hier
dieses ganze wohnzimmer mit einem
esstisch für sechs leute hier sind
stühle
lasst mich erstmal nicht einfach re wie
das zimmer 2 weil zu klasse ist von
wasser zeitpunkt nachzumachen zeitraum
das machst du alle bilder ab
und die hängt alles an so viel wie man
das sehen kann so ganz normal halt wie
man bilder aufhängen zu schieben und ich
mache also bei allen bildern machen
überreden will der kreis schritt merkel
vom boden alles weg und da kommt das
heftigste das ist mir gar nicht
aufgefallen
bei maximal den ganzen globally fall ist
er was habe ich verloren weil sie über
ihnen will so dass da einfach raus und
das ist halt irgendwas ich glaube alaba
welches zeit die man ins licht ist es
richtig praise of baby macht aber so zum
fun macht ihr einfach alle dinge und es
ist glaube ich ein aber das kokain oder
so was ähnliches kokain nur die mütze
geben dessen weißes klares bürger dran
das witzige waren gestern euro und
letztlich event wohl los geht nämlich
auch markus leuthe das ist vor allem
locker in gramm oder so das wird noch
richtig viel mehr das ist was ich 100
euro oder sogar mehr ich hab keine
heilige kunst wäre es aber das lokal
richtig teuer und wir haben einfach
dieses verfluchte kokain durchdachtes
rechts immer gebunden auf sparflamme
fahren so ja machen
max muss ein zug bekommen was alles
kaputt damit den verpasst und dann
finden wir einfach fucking koks oder
weiß ich was für drogen also das ist
echt ich meine klar das thema ist ultras
und man könnte sie denken dass er über
welche reichen business menschen drin
sind und ja mal durchziehen und ist aber
das sagt kux verstecken er sein
das ding ist halt auch wir haben gerade
überlegt was wir 100.000 leicht einfach
mal ausprobieren den live verkostung nie
aber es war etwas reiterfreunde ich
finde es echt krass
falling slowly ich glaube dass wir so
wenig dass hier runtergebracht hat wieso
ist während übel aus der wand aber ich
finde von der von der konsistenz dass
mosaic guckst du bist einfach wuchs das
ist so herzlich lachen wir jetzt damit
alle keine ahnung wie das team und
hergeben müssen wir einige kanten drin
ich zeige noch ganz gut das hotel das
hotel fertig weil es weil das zimmer ist
echt ultra krass also leute hier ist
übrigens einfach die erste toilette hier
und hier das große spiegel
also es ist richtig cool und noch
einfach unglaublich nett von dem hotel
dass sie das baby ich mache gerade das
duo versteckt haben beschlüsse und auch
dass die mir so ein upgrade gegeben
haben aber dann macht er wie nichts
ahnende einfach diese ganzen bilder aber
das geht einfach fakten koks und wir
gehen jetzt mal zu den anderen und das
einfach weil was ist das damit war ich
laufe mit koks einfach um
irgendwo in china gut wir haben ja ich
meine auch video das gefunden haben aber
es ist einfach crazy
wir gehen jetzt noch zu prüfen da sitzen
noch sami slimani und macht einen abriss
oder smid nennt ich habe aus spaß oder
zeitdruck hatte habe ich alle bilder an
den wänden konventen abgemacht und
wieder ein wilko risser ausgefallen ist
hinter so einem bilderrahmen hier
vorgefallen betriebs hat die innenseite
vom 22
also leute ist es richtig kreativ was
machen wir damit ist
ich bin jetzt wieder zurück in meinem
hotelzimmer und ich muss jetzt mal mit
dem packen anfangen weil ich schon
ziemlich spät dran wenn du dich die
ganze schicht hat sich das alles noch
mal verzögert aber ich muss wirklich
also ich hatte einfach keine andere wahl
als das in einem video festzuhalten
ich meine wie krank ist das schnell im
war for children hat vollidioten wir
dabei bei euch im zimmer und der hängt
die bilder 100 klinik einfach koks coke
ist einfach
also ich weiss es klar man sagt immer so
hier bis uns menschen und so sollen das
des öfteren mark konsumieren allerdings
war richtig gut wir waren gerade bei der
rezeption einfach und der typ sagte
wieder regen so herrlich wirklich will
das ist nicht haben was soll ich da
machen also ja nehmen oder wie
geschmiert
als christ ich brauch aber nochmal
großes großes dankeschön an das armani
hotel dass sie mir das upgrade gegeben
haben einfach richtig lustig meint
logischerweise die finden das nicht wenn
da hier reinigungskräfte sind ein gucken
ja nicht hinter den dann gucken ja nicht
hinter dem ganzen
danach ob er irgendwie was versteckt
sein könnte also dem hotel kann man da
absolut keine vorwürfe machen aber
einfach koks die beiden zimmerleute
wissen einfach vorstellen und nichts an
und seid ihr einfach in diesem hotel und
40 fällt einfach koks aus also ich gehe
jetzt mal schwer davon aus dass ich weiß
selbst nicht genau aber ich mein so ein
weißes pulver in kleinen döschen also
mich würd's sehr überraschen wenn es
wenn es irgendwas anderes wäre so leute
ich habe es jetzt tatsächlich geschafft
ich habe meinen zug erwischt und es ist
schon ein paar tage später
mir ist im schnitt aufgefallen dass sie
mich ein bisschen häufig wiederholt habe
bei dem ganzen video weil ich halt
einfach so geflasht war und so und es
ging mir einfach jetzt vor allen dingen
glauben dass ich euch einfach einfach
dieses erlebnis teile weil es war total
krass irgendwie dass man einfach drogen
gefunden hat ich meine ich bin ich ganz
sicher auf solche sind aber fangen ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher
ich habe jetzt auch nicht so viele
aufnahmen von dem
hotelzimmer wie ich eigentlich gerne
gehabt hätte ein paar habe ich noch
vielleicht kann ich euch jetzt noch mal
kurz was zusammenschneiden
aber ja das soll es gewesen sein von dem
heutigen videos war jetzt ein bisschen
unüblich aber ich hoffe es hat euch
trotzdem gefallen
falls ja stockem ein leichter und schaut
auf buy sowie vorbei dann habe ich
verlinkt und einzigen erst beim nächsten
mal wieder macht's gut und tschüss